à montbéliard tient en duplex allez
retrouver un étudiant en deuxième année
de dut carrières sociales et l'iut de
belfort montbéliard
bonjour a fait lever ce n'est bon jour
pascal merci d'être avec nous alors en
ce moment en pologne
il ya 197 pays pour le sommet de la
terre si la coop 24 et vous vous avez
trouvé une façon originale de parler
environnement a compté moi cette
aventure raphaël et bien dans le cadre
du festival des solidarités que on a
organisé à belfort on a décidé
d'organiser une simulation de sept top
24 qui se déroule à katowice est
effectivement en pologne et qu'on a
simulé avec la présence de quatorze pays
les 14 qui nous semblaient les plus
importants pour avoir toutes ces
délibérations internationales sur les
enjeux climatiques mondiaux et les
enjeux climatiques propres à chaque
chacun des pays représentés
donc finalement à fel vous avez fait une
fausse coop 24 si j'ai bien compris il
ya 197 pays en ce moment en pologne pour
parler d'environnement vous vous y tenir
un petit peu moins de vingt pays est ce
que ça veut dire que la négociation a
été plus facile et puis dans quel but
vous avez fait ça surtout rafale alors
effectivement la négociation a été d
bien plus facile et n'empêche qu'on a
pris une bonne heure et demie à trouver
un seul accord une seule proposition a
été acceptée en une heure et demie
c'est pour ces pour bien montrer à quel
point c'est difficile de trouver des
désaccords par consensus
le but c'était vraiment que les
étudiants se rendent compte à quel point
il est difficile de légiférer sur le
climat au niveau international au niveau
mondial et peut-être qu'ils se disent
que c'est un autre jouer si les états
peuvent pas faire le travail
alors c'est une façon différente de
parler environnement j'ai bien compris
vous avez choisi vos 17 pays comment
finalement raphaël on a choisi les
enjeux les plus différents on a mis
aussi les grands
pollueurs les états unis la chine la
russie on a mis des tout petits pays
comme les fidji le niger où la
centrafrique qui représentait les pays
les plus touchés et les plus menacées
par le réchauffement climatique comme
ceux qui sont les plus acteur de ce
réchauffement là alors on vous voit là
on a lu quelques images concrètement
vous vous êtes réunis dans des
amphithéâtres et avec tous vos camarades
qui représentait les différents pays
vous avez tout poser sur la table vous
avez discuté vous avez fait quoi
concrètement
alors tout d'abord on a eu une
présentation du rapport du giec du
groupement intergouvernemental d'experts
au climat qui a sorti un rapport cette
année ils ont une présentation de ce
rapport la très rapide
ensuite ils sont réunis pour définir les
orientations qu'ils voulaient prendre
dans les négociations qu'ils allaient
faire par la suite
on a eu un moment de forums de
discussion avec la société civile avec
différentes entreprises et différentes
associations ong qui étaient représentés
pour amener aussi des savoirs théoriques
et scientifique sur la question et
ensuite une fois que les 14 pays avaient
présenté leur leurs orientations et les
actions concrètes qu'il proposait on a
eu une bonne heure de négociations en
amphithéâtre avec le même procédé que
lors d'une vraie coop une décision par
consensus avec un seul porte parole par
pays qui avait le droit de s'exprimer
pendant 30 secondes maximum par par
prise de parole pour que ce soit le plus
réaliste possible
j'imagine que là vous avez eu conscience
de la difficulté d'une négociation
et puis la satisfaction des demandes
aussi parce que on se rend compte que
dans ces cas là c'est particulièrement
compliqué pour arriver à quelque chose
effectivement ça prend énormément de
temps
chaque chaque pays a ses problématiques
on doit satisfaire chaque pays et on a
trouvé un consensus parce qu'on n'est
pas scientifique et qu'on n'a pas
forcément tous les éléments pour trouver
des vrais
des vraies propositions qui dut un fonds
concret mais mais une araignée pour une
proposition ça vous laisse voir à 197
pays avec des vrais enjeux
ce que ça peut donner raphaël baisse
mais au final vous êtes tombés d'accord
sur une proposition si j'ai bien compris
de quoi s'agit-il
la valeur de cette proposition est toute
relative mais la proposition qui a été
acceptée c'était une baisse de 50% de la
consommation des énergies fossiles pour
les 20 plus gros pollueurs de 40% pour
le reste des pays à horizon 2040 avec la
création d'un fonds international pour
le climat où chaque pays verserait 1 %
de son pib
c'est irréaliste et en même temps ça
nous paraît beaucoup mais c'est peu car
il faudrait atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 si on veut rester sous
la barre des deux degrés c'est ça fait
beaucoup réfléchir et ça fait beaucoup
réfléchir les étudiants et justement les
étudiants vous avez senti qu ils ont
accroché ou alors vraiment c'est parce
que c'était un devoir comme un autre
finalement ils étaient obligés de
négocier avec vous appelle non non on a
été vraiment très très content de
l'implication des étudiants ils se sont
quasiment tous impliqués à fond dans
dans les négociations ils ont pris leur
rôle très à coeur et on n'attendait pas
une participation aussi aussi forte des
étudiants on a été vraiment vraiment
ravi même si on est un petit peu déçu
par le fait que les différents chefs de
département des autres départements de
l'iut de belfort montbéliard et pas
forcément répondu très positivement à la
demande qui leur avaient été envoyés de
de banaliser des cours pour que certains
de leurs étudiants puissent participer
avec les étudiants carrières sociales
en tout cas vous m'arrêtez si je me
trompe raphaël mais c'est une façon
différente et originale surtout parler
d'environnement c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
effectivement c'est sa soeur du schéma
qu'on a d'habitude de sensibiliser par
des quiz
de faire culpabiliser de montrer des
films les les étudiants se rendent
vraiment acteurs des négociations
internationales
c'est une expérience unique où on vit
rarement deux fois
il faut aussi merci